Having now gotten their first glimpse of
"Despicable Me 4," fans are left wondering just
how time in this animated world works, exactly. It
seems to pass for some and stay frozen for others.
The first trailer for "Despicable Me 4" has now
dropped, giving fans a taste of the Minion madness
to come this summer. While the clip doesn't give
away too much about the plot, it nevertheless
promises the same spy-style antics, charming
family dynamics, and zany comedy that audiences
have come to know and love over the animated
franchise's 14 years of box office domination.
One of the most interesting
developments in "Despicable
Me 4" involves Gru and Lucy's new baby, Gru Jr.
"Something is missing!"
"This guy!"
"Oh-ho! There's my boy!"
HIs introduction is certain to be
a new source of adorable mayhem and
heartwarming moments as the infant learns
to bond with Gru. But for longtime fans,
the baby's inclusion also opened
up a perplexing question about the
"Despicable Me" franchise as a whole. One
Redditor was among the many viewers asking,
"This is the fourth movie and Gru has a baby now,
so why are those girls not aging? They look
the exact same as they did in the first movie."
It's unlikely that fans would have such
a problem with the lack of aging of Gru's
adopted daughters Margo, Edith, and Agnes,
had Gru not had a bouncing baby boy. But
now that the family has welcomed its newest
member, things are more confusing than ever.
Another Redditor observed,
"Giving gru and Lucy a baby but not
aging up the girls is crazy lmao."
Over on X, formerly known as
Twitter, a user compared the
odd choice to characters in the
"Dragon Ball" universe, saying,
"4 movies in and the girls haven't aged up
They got the goten and trunks treatment."
The decision to give Gru a baby
while leaving his daughters the
same age has some fans trying to grasp
the logistics of the "Despicable Me"
universe. Describing seeing the trailer as a
"mind-bending moment," another X user asked,
"How's Gru got a kid and those girls haven't
aged a day? What's the timeline of these movies?"
If the events of the "Despicable Me"
movies actually took place in real time,
then the fourth movie would occur
seven years after the last adventure,
meaning that the girls should have grown up
quite a bit. However, fans have determined that
the franchise's timeline doesn't match the real
world's. One such fan on X suggested of Gru Jr.,
"The kid's [only] a few months old,
a year tops. Throwing in pregnancy,
I'd say we're only 18-24
months after the last film."
Fans have also theorized that 2013's
"Despicable Me 2" takes place a year
after the 2010 original. If that same logic
is applied to "Despicable Me 3," then it's
not too much of a stretch to buy into the series
taking place within a five to 10-year timeframe.
While some fans are struggling to wrap their
heads around the age of Gru's daughters,
others don't see such a reason
to sweat over the matter. In a
franchise full of over-the-top villains,
crazy gadgets, and goofy yellow goons,
it's safe to chalk up such lingering questions to
good ol' cartoon logic. One Redditor compared how
the characters in "Despicable Me" age — or don't
— to another famous animated family, writing,
"Audiences aren't watching these movies to see
the characters grow up with the viewer. It's
the exact same as 'The Simpsons' where we know
what to expect without any needless changes."
"Oh, Bart, cartoons don't have
to be 100 percent realistic."
Nevertheless, it closes the door to a
potential opportunity for the "Despicable
Me" to defy expectations. Another Redditor argued,
"Given that the first one was genuinely
very emotional and heartfelt and was
about him becoming a dad, instead
of all this stuff with Lucy and a
new baby they could've so easily done a
sillier version of a 'Toy Story' style
'kids growing up and dad has to accept
it' type thing across a few films."
What makes Gru's daughters seeming to stay the
same age so frustrating is that it hampers their
development as characters and their relationship
with Gru. Since the first film saw them turn the
once villainous Gru into a loving father, the
girls haven't had as much presence within the
franchise. Aging them up and having Gru deal with
the difficulties that come with parenting preteens
could have given the sequel an amount of heart
that would surely surprise kids and parents alike.
It's unlikely that such lingering questions
will deter viewers from seeing "Despicable Me
4," but it will certainly keep some scratching
their heads until its release on July 3, 2024.